-Well, today was Thanksgiving,
so if you haven't gotten around
to arguing with your family
about politics yet,
allow me to change that
by spending the next
12 to 14 minutes discussing
the 2024 presidential election
and specifically
the various ways
in which Donald Trump
is very bad.
Brace yourselves.
It's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's Thanksgiving, which means
it's the end of a long day
where everyone's
been chugging red wine
and awkwardly smiling
at uncomfortable family stories
like Ron DeSantis
on a debate stage.
And if you're watching this
on Thanksgiving,
there's a good chance you either
are or are with a weird uncle.
Now, if you're
with a weird uncle,
blink once to let us know
you're okay.
And if you are a weird uncle,
blink 1,000 times like you did
when your niece told everyone
how she met her girlfriend
at Brown.
Perfect. We're off. It's great
to be with all of you.
And, by the way, I just want
to say I personally have
nothing against weird uncles.
We all have them.
They play an integral role
in the family dynamic.
That's how younger generations
learn about stuff like
pull my finger,
members-only jackets,
"Svengoolie," off-track betting,
and the non-pillow products
sold by Mike Lindell.
"Yeah, he makes
great slippers, too,
but the liberal media
won't tell you about that.
He even got a whole line
of fake mustaches
called MyStache.
Touch it. Feels real, right?
Yeah, they make it
from horsehair.
I don't know. I think they grab
the tails while they run by."
So weird uncles are fine,
but there is a delicate balance
when one enters an ecosystem.
A solitary weird uncle?
That's manageable.
But too many weird uncles,
and chaos is upon you.
And that's what's happened
to American politics,
which in recent years has become
dominated by weird uncles,
guys like Lindell or
Steve Bannon or Rudy Giuliani.
In fact, the weird uncles
all seem to gravitate toward
each other and team up together
kind of like Voltron
if Voltron had a Ziploc full of
pills in his glove compartment.
Just this week,
Lindell was on Bannon's
streaming show or podcast
or transmission from his volcano
lair or whatever the hell it is,
where Lindell claimed that a
recent judge's ruling in Georgia
that had nothing to do with him
and did not even
mention his name
had somehow vindicated him
for spreading election lies,
proving that he is not
a conspiracy theorist.
He even brought props
and a costume
to really drive home the point.
-Well, first of all, Steve, I
get to take off my tinfoil hat.
You know, that's what
that judge said.
We're not a conspiracy-theory
guy anymore. Praise the Lord.
-First of all, I love --
I love that we're at the point
where Mike Lindell
is actually wearing the things
I used to ask my graphics team
to Photoshop on top of him.
Second of all,
that's not what tinfoil hats
are supposed to look like.
They're pointy.
You don't just wrap tinfoil
around a baseball cap.
You look like a cabby
from a bad sci-fi movie.
Hand it to Mike Lindell,
who can do a thing
only crazy people do
in a way that is even crazier.
If you were wearing
a regular tinfoil hat
on the subway, and Mike Lindell
sat down next to you in his,
you'd move to the next car.
"That guy is [bleep] crazy!
Where was I?
Oh, the government's
sending brainwaves."
Third, did you mean
to take off your glasses?
I mean, was that part
of the costume?
You're not Clark Kent, dude.
We know it's you.
Look like a side character from
the "Where's Waldo" universe
called Loony Lindell.
I think Lindell's real fear
is that if he keeps
wearing the glasses,
he might see where
he screwed up the math
and realize he's wrong
about the election results.
[as Lindell]
"The vote totals were
manipulated by the machines!
You can see here
that they don't add up!
And, oh, wait a second.
Oh, brother. Hold on.
I thought that 7 was a 2.
That changes everything.
Okay. Joe Biden's
definitely president.
My bad!"
Nonetheless, this gang
of weirdos in Trump's orbit
is once again
inching closer to power
as polls show
the presidential race
is essentially a dead heat
just a year before the election.
Trump has promised
that this time around,
he'll stock his administration
with loyalists
who obediently follow
his every command,
and his former aides
from his first term,
like his ex-chief of staff,
John Kelly,
have been out there
sounding the alarm
about just how bad
that would be.
-"The Washington Post"
interviewed
16 former Trump advisers
who are now speaking out
against him publicly.
And that includes John Kelly,
who was the longest-serving
chief of staff
for the former president.
Kelly tells the newspaper this.
"What's going on in the country
that a single person
thinks this guy
would still be
a good president
when he's said
the things he said
and done the things he's done?
It's beyond my comprehension
he has the support he has.
I think we're in a dangerous
zone in our country."
-I do appreciate the warning
he's trying to give us,
but Kelly saying
we're in a dangerous zone now
is like one of those
weather guys
who reports live from inside
a category-five hurricane,
clinging to a light pole
while a shark swims by
in waist-deep floodwater,
saying, "The wind's really
starting to pick up out here!
You might want
to rethink your picnic!
And if you do have any food,
make sure to wrap it up
like this!"
I also love
when it finally dawns
on these former Trump guys
how the rest of us have felt
for the last seven years.
It's 2023,
and suddenly they're like,
"Oh, goodness. I don't get it.
How can people support this guy?
You worked for him!
It's like if someone said,
"How can anyone listen
to Hall and Oates?"
And you turned around
to see who it was,
and it was [bleep] Oates.
So Trump's former aides
are now speaking out
because they can't believe
he's actually
in a dead heat with Biden.
And Trump has made his plans
extremely clear.
If he wins a second term,
he'll weaponize
the Justice Department
to crush enemies
he's referred to as "vermin."
That's not an exaggeration.
That's an exact quote.
"The Washington Post" reported
that Trump and his allies
will seek revenge
in a second term,
and Trump himself
has admitted as much
in rallies and interviews.
-According to recent
"Washington Post" reporting,
"Donald Trump and his allies
have begun
mapping out specific plans
for using the federal government
to punish critics and opponents
should he win a second term,
with the former president
naming individuals
he wants to investigate
or prosecute."
-We will start by exposing
every last crime committed
by Crooked Joe Biden
because now that he indicted me,
we're allowed to look at him.
This is third-world-country
stuff.
Arrest your --
Arrest your opponent.
And that means
that I could do that, too.
If they want to
follow through on this,
yeah, it could certainly
happen in reverse.
It could certainly happen
in reverse.
What they've done is
they've released the genie
out of the box.
-Yes.
Famously, that is the saying.
They released the genie
out of the box,
they opened Pandora's Lamp,
and they let the cat out
of solitary confinement.
And, look, this couldn't be
further down my list
of complaints
about Donald Trump,
but genies live
in lamps or bottles,
you know, things with openings
that are conducive
to smoke-based beings
making a dramatic exit.
How would a genie
even come out of a box?
You just rub the sides
of random DHL packages,
and if you get lucky,
a voice from inside says,
"I am the genie of the box!
You're gonna need to poke
a hole in the side for me!"
And I'll tell you this much.
There's no way a box genie
has three wishes to give.
If a genie's in a box,
that genie's in a bad place
in his life.
If anything, he's gonna need
to borrow a wish from you.
"Genie of the box,
I wish for fame and fortune."
"Oh, that's a good one.
Wish I thought of that one.
I used my last wish to get
Aaron Rodgers on the Jets."
[Bleep] the bed on that one.
Should have wished
for stronger ankles.
Okay, I think I'm gonna
get back in my box now."
Also, can we go back to this?
-This is third-world-country
stuff.
Arrest your --
Arrest your opponent.
And that means
that I could do that, too.
-Only Trump would call something
"third-world" in one sentence
and then immediately brag about
doing it in the next sentence.
"It's disgusting
what they're doing to me.
Only a truly appalling,
cretinous, subhuman monster
would ever stoop to such
grotesque and horrifying lows.
Which is why I'm very excited
to announce...
that I will soon be doing
the exact same thing!"
Of course,
there's a massive difference
between what Trump
is promising to do
and what prosecutors
are currently doing to Trump.
Trump is facing four
different criminal cases,
including one
in Washington, D.C.,
for what we all saw
with our own eyes --
his attempt
to overturn the election.
Trump, on the other hand,
wants revenge
because he's still fixated
on all the investigations
of his very obvious
criminal behavior.
At rallies, he's started
doing a new bit where
he compares his indictments
to those of Al Capone,
although the stories
about Capone keep changing.
Here's the latest version.
-I've been indicted more times
than Alphonse Capone.
He's the most vicious
of all gangsters.
If he took you to dinner
and if you didn't look proper,
if you laughed a little bit,
he might think
you're laughing at him.
It's dangerous to laugh.
He'd kill you immediately.
He was indicted one time.
I was indicted four times.
-Okay, so he definitely
is thinking
of the famous scene
from "Goodfellas."
He probably thinks Joe Pesci
is Al Capone.
"Al Capone,
the most vicious of gangsters.
The only two people
who could take him down
were Eliot Ness
and Kevin McCallister.
You know, I met
Kevin McCallister once.
He was lost in New York.
It was very sad. Very sad."
Also, it shouldn't bother me
this much, but I hate --
I hate how he says
"Alphonse Capone."
He's so proud he knows
what the "Al" is short for.
He knows one fact,
and he's walking around
like he's Ken Jennings.
He probably only knows it
because a box genie told him.
"For my first wish,
I want to be president again."
"Oh, no can do.
That's way above my pay grade.
I can tell you what Al Capone's
full name is, though.
You want that?
That's not a wish, but
it's a pretty good fun factoid.
Alright. I'm gonna
get back in the box. Enh."
[ Laughter ]
So Trump wants to seek revenge
on his critics
because he's fixated
on all the investigations
he's been through.
He's even still obsessed
with the Russia investigation.
At a rally just a few days ago,
he went out of his way
to bring up one of
the more salacious rumors
that was flying around about
his personal life back in 2017.
-This is the greatest
witch hunt.
It started with
Russia, Russia, Russia.
Remember that?
"He was with four hookers."
You think that was good
that night to go up
and tell my wife,
"It's not true, darling.
I love you very much.
It's not true."
Actually, that one she didn't
believe because she said,
"He's a germaphobe.
He's not into that." You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
"He's not into golden showers,
as they say they call them.
He's not."
I don't like that idea.
[ Applause ]
No, I didn't. I thought
that would be a big problem.
I was gonna have a rough night.
But that one,
she was very good on.
She said, "No, that --
You're okay on that one."
-Dude, not even Democrats
are thinking
about the pee tape anymore!
But when you come out
six years later
and deny a story
everybody forgot about,
I have to think, heh,
maybe it's true.
If someone came up to you
at your 20th high-school reunion
and said, "By the way,
I'm not the one
who put the sardines
in your locker,"
then you just solved that case.
My favorite part is when he said
Melania didn't believe
"that one."
Like there are plenty
of other stories
she definitely believed.
"She didn't believe
the golden-shower story,
but when the news broke that
I asked a porn star to spank me
with a 'Forbes' magazine
while we watched 'Shark Week,'
she said,
'That sounds like my Donald.'"
[ Laughter ]
Also, let me just say
I never believed
the golden-shower story, either.
I mean, Trump barely looks like
he takes regular showers.
I mean, look at him.
He's always red-faced
and sweating
like he's been in the kitchen
all day making
Thanksgiving dinner,
accidentally sticking
his own head in the oven.
You don't need a doctor
to tell you this isn't healthy.
Even the Butterball hotline
would take one look at this pic
and be like, "He's overcooked!"
It looks like he should
be served on a plate
next to some yams
and a green-bean casserole.
[ Laughter ]
So it's Thanksgiving.
It's Thanksgiving.
Which means we're just under
a year away from the election.
Everyone's taking stock
of where we're at.
Thanks to the GOP,
our national politics
has basically been turned into
a nonstop Thanksgiving dinner
made up entirely
of weird uncles.
And if Trump wins a second term,
his administration
will be full of weird uncles,
except now
they'll have real power.
So let that thought
sit with you tonight
while you're pouring
all of that delicious gravy
all over those
oven-roasted turkeys.
Honestly, I'm getting hungry
just thinking about those...
-Golden showers!
[ Laughter ]
-Happy Thanksgiving!
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, everybody. Thanks
for watching "A Closer Look."
And as a reminder,
my brother Josh and I
have started a new podcast
called "Family Trips
with the Meyers Brothers."
We hope you listen. We hope
you like it. And see you soon.